before we begin since this is a BBC
owned property I feel the need to point
out that the news armor the BBC has a
continuing issue with transphobic
leanings in its news coverage you can
find in a pinned comment below various
videos from both myself and other
YouTubers covering this issue and while
I understand that the Doctor Who
creative team is not responsible for
this I will continue to point this out
for as long as it remains a consistent
issue thank you
orphans really do have a tough don't
they
all right
[Music]
foreign
take two Doctor Who reviews carry on and
it's time to revisit
orphan 55.
this one has been a bit notorious right
from its first airing and
um not unjustly
this is a weird one
and I am going to say weird more than
I'm gonna say bad because
the ways in which it doesn't work and it
is bad
are not standard like there's a weird
honestly I can't help but feel that the
script
was trying for something different than
what the director was trying for what do
I mean by that well there's a fair
amount of stuff
that's in here that's pretty camp
pretty ridiculous feels like it wasn't
really meant to be taken seriously on
paper a lot of this comes across as more
light-hearted with like an environmental
thing running as an undercard but then
when it was shot and filmed it was all
done very dramatically and treated
seriously with serious lighting and
music and all ominous and
it doesn't
it doesn't click
because you've got stuff like a
character named hyphen with a three you
have an aliens that the thing that
designates them as aliens is their hair
is green you have a character who's
introduced sucking her thumb you have
this old couple and all the weirdness
that goes on with how many is uh
presented and that whole thing
and it feels like it's trying to well
how fun might be the wrong word but it's
it feels like it's trying to
just poke at all these things that it's
not presenting this is a big dramatic
thing as like a boy in this kind of
ridiculous but then the presentation is
so straight faced
and given that Ed Heim who wrote the
script for this also wrote it takes you
away which I love
part of me one there's one of two things
and it's a question of whether or not I
want to let Ed Heim off the hook in
specific
so the version uh that is not his fault
is that he wrote a script that was meant
to have a not particularly serious tone
but it was approached completely
straightfaced in a way that meant a lot
of more outwardly ridiculous elements
are clashing with the tone of the thing
that's the version that's not his fault
the version that is his fault is that he
just wrote a mess
and maybe he even wrote a mess with it
takes you away but it just happened to
line up in a way that worked you get
that sometimes sometimes you'll get
writers who or creators in general who
what they do like that doesn't work but
like every now and then the stars align
and the thing that they do
somehow all fits together and clicks and
you're like oh
okay that does work but then you try and
take in more of their work and it turns
out to be a fluke
sometimes that happens I don't know if
that's the case with that Heim but those
are kind of the two possibilities I see
I'm talking broad stroke so far let's
get into this thing the there's there's
it's hard to know where to start there's
a lot of weirdness so they they just get
teleported in to this Resort and
there is a lot of potential
in the core idea of a resort that's
actually on a blasted hellscape of a
planet
but you wouldn't know that while you're
in the resort because it's within this
self-contained safety bubble that also
makes it look like everything's all nice
out there there's certainly things to be
done there especially that tie in with
the environmental message in terms of
you know maybe I mean the most obvious
thing is like if this is the protective
Dome where people of means go
and ignore all of the trial the
destruction that's out there certainly
could have done that there's even hints
of that it's like talked about as if
that's the theme but it can't be it
doesn't fit so like it's brought up when
it talks about the evacuation of the
planet and when we're getting into the
backstory
it's brought up that people of means
evacuated the planet and left everybody
else here so that idea of a class divide
of those with means not having to suffer
the consequences is in the text but not
in the story it's literally talked about
but the thing is the part of the reason
this Resort is built here is because
it's cheaper to build it here which also
means they can offer it at more of a
discount maybe there's some people here
who are of means but like the doctor and
her companions want a contest
the you know we're seeing the workers
who are not people of means
you know the the old couple they come
across you know more like elderly people
on a cruise not of means but of like
they're retired and they have a little
money uh to use like people are coming
across more as middle class-esque this
is not the ruling Elite who abandoned
the planet so even bringing up that idea
when it is not on display with the rest
of what's going on
is weird and then there's all the twists
with the fact that this is Earth
the first thing is it's weird to me that
that twist happens with like
10 12 minutes left to go
because
it there's a reason that things like the
Planet of the Apes save that twist for
the ending because it's a gut punch if
you do it right
but you do it earlier and then you keep
going
it's it's an odd choice and it's made
more odd because not everyone learns it
at the same time doctor figures it out
first other characters figure it out
later and then we end with kind of a
lecture on it and I suppose we might as
well deal with that since we brought it
up the ending speech from the doctor
all right here's the thing
it could have worked if they'd stopped
it a lot sooner like they stopped it
after basically the first couple of
sentences would have been fine would
have been solid you want me to tell you
the Earth's gonna be okay
because I can't but after that like
she's she's delivering this as if it's
the fault of her companions like there
in action caused the problem which it's
not the future is not fixed it depends
on billions of decisions and actions and
people stepping up
a bit like it reminds me how bad this
show was at trying to to criticize
capitalism in kerblam that's the
absolute wrong way to deal with the
actual problems of environmental
degradation because the issues are are
maybe not necessarily help but are not
caused by
your companions nor is it caused by the
average viewer it's caused by major
corporations
they are the ones dumping millions and
millions and millions of tons of carbon
into the atmosphere
not you for you know driving your car to
the corner instead of walking would it
be better for you to walk yes
but like
that's a drop
in the ocean whereas what these
corporations do is freaking tsunamis
so like it's wrong-headed in the first
dang place especially being delivered
directly to the companions
we're like what did they do
and what what do you expect them to do
like the only way I could see this
working is if
Environmental
um protection and and and pushing to fix
that becomes a running theme throughout
the series and it doesn't I mean it
comes up again in praxius which to my
memory is better than this one but like
it's not running through it as much of a
major theme as like say capitalism was
in series 10. so I
it's weird it's a weird choice and the
dregs all right I mean first of all
let's just gloss over the fact that
that's not how Evolution works like I
and I understand Evolution can happen
from random mutations but like
species don't randomly mutate the
ability to literally breathe the exact
opposite of what they used to breathe
like we currently breathe in oxygen and
exhale carbon dioxide and these things
suddenly breathe carbon dioxide and
exhale oxygen
that's not how Evolution works but let's
move past that it's soft science
whatever
but here's another thing that's weird is
that the drags the way they are shot
early on it's very
alien-esque like the movie Alien they
are kept in the shadows tight close-ups
you know dripping off the fangs we don't
get a clear look they're fairly
effective at that point but then later
on we see them out in open daylight they
don't look nearly as good there's even a
couple shots that are like that looks
really CGI maybe it's maybe it's a bad
green screen composite I don't know but
there's some shots where like these
things look terrible
and
it kind of It kind of again just shows
like not understanding what you're
working with because you'd think with
the way that they're shot early on that
it's leaning into the fact that these
things don't look great if we just show
them so we'll shoot them this way so it
works but then we do get a clear look at
them so it seems to be more like oh
we'll hide them until we get the big
reveal of our great monster but it's not
a great monster it's not very good
you should have kept it in the shadows
and we've got the whole thing with Bella
who like is established as being
unemployed so again with that this is
not the ruling Elites vacationing year
thing
um but you know she's here for her mom
so like this is our second episode in a
row bringing mommy issues to the
Forefront
not sure why but that did stick out to
me I don't want to dwell on the on the
stuff with with sorry Benny I don't want
to dwell on that
um the thing was it was so weird I
actually kind of oddly liked it the
first time I saw it just because like it
was so out of left field I don't think I
really knew how to process it because it
is weird
this whole thing with him holding a full
conversation from outside
you know while clearly in tons of pain
uh it's
the and the way that dialogue and that
that conversation flows is really
bizarre and then later on when
um when the when the woman whose name I
don't remember I only remember
but when she runs into somebody else
like did you see
but don't worry I killed him
mostly I laughed at that because again
it's such an absurd line it feels like
it's supposed to be funny but nothing
about the delivery and the shooting
style and the lighting or any of the
rest of it presents it as funny so again
it makes me wonder if there's a
disconnect between the script and the
director but like even beyond the
weirdness and stuff that doesn't gel
like
this is an idiot plot if you're not
familiar with that term it's a it's a
term for a story or a plot that only
goes the way it does because people act
like idiots
you know not because of characters wants
or desires or you know character choices
that make logical sense people just act
stupid like from its very conception the
idea of this Resort on Orphan 55 is
already a stupid idea so our premise is
predicated on people being stupid and
then like let's go out and look for this
old guy and and let's take everybody
with us like I support Doctor Who go out
and trying to save everybody always but
like let's take everyone with us
out into this area
surrounded by all these monsters that
are trying to kill everything that's a
stupid decision then we have Bella who
yo she wants to get back at her mom's
show she's going to blow up an entire
Resort and kill how many people so she's
an idiot right down to tiny little
things like there's the maintenance guy
in his kid and at one point the kid gets
annoyed and storms off but like he
leaves the room where they're all locked
in and safe and storms off into the
hallway where the dregs are even if I
make allowances for the kids are dumb
like that's bed but that's gonna drive a
bit of the plot for a little bit
the plot exists in the shape that it
does because
almost everyone's a [ __ ]
and just does stupid things
this I I can't hate this episode
because it it just it doesn't anger me
but it confounds me
I feel like this is probably never gonna
be good but like there's some disconnect
somewhere
that resulted in it being this bizarrely
bad
because it's not even a case where like
I see the idea but it didn't quite pull
together which is how I feel like say
loving monsters but this like
I'm not entirely sure what you were
going for
or if everybody was on the same page for
what the goal was here
it's just really weird it's clunky it is
bad but I feel like weird is the better
descriptor than like bad or worst
episode ever like it's just it's just
weird man it's weird in a bad way
because like it takes you away was weird
but that was weird in a good way this is
weird in a bad way but just I don't know
I don't know this thing's kind of a mess
orphan 55 have you re-watched this what
are your thoughts on it whatever they
are drop something down in the comments
let's talk about it patreon's what pays
the bills and enables me to do this as
my living any amount that you can
support is of great assistance even if
you can't like share subscribe help me
out but don't worry too much about that
either because what I really want you to
remember is that you are beautiful
you are valid
and you are loved
you are the council I'm just running the
meetings and until next time this
Council is adjourned
[Music]
end of the video so I got a shout out my
top patrons Robin Moore Zubin with fulla
Tarak the thing that goes doink in the
anime Oliver B Angus bjornison Melinda
Walters imudelki the oatha Boyd catoria
toyololi Becky Sparks for nabilax the
poodle Zach Tracy scrabot angry Casper
Tim price Adam r d l Taylor Shayla
gourlay and Brendan Larose
thanks for your support if you want to
hear me probably mispronounce your name
as well check out the rewards on the
patreon
what you doing there
[Music]